the next best predictor of lifetime
success is conscientiousness well so and
although of the two aspects of
conscientiousness say orderliness and
and industriousness the better predictor
is industriousness so the question is
well what can you do about your
industriousness and the answer to that
is well that's kind of rough too because
there's a strong genetic component but
you can work on micro habits with
regards to your conscientiousness and I
think the best micro habits this is
partly to do with these future authoring
program processes I think the best thing
you can do with regards to your
conscientiousness is to set up some aims
for yourself goals that you actually
value and the future authoring program
helps people do that and basically it
does a situational analysis of it helps
you do a situational analysis of your
life more than a psychological analysis
I would say and so the questions are
something like well alright you're going
to have to put some effort into your
life and you need to be motivated to do
that and so what are the potential
sources of motivation well you could
think about them in in the Big Five
manner you know if you're extroverted
you want friends if you're agreeable you
want an intimate relationship if you're
disagreeable you want to win
competitions if you're open you want to
engage in creative activity if you're
high in eroticism you want security okay
so those are all sources of potential
motivation that you could draw on that
you could tailor to your own you know
your own personality but then there are
dimensions that you want to consider
your life across and so we asked people
about well you know if you could have
your life the way you wanted it in three
to five years if you were taking care of
yourself properly you know what would
you want from your friendships what
would you want from your intimate
relationship how would you like to
structure your family what do you want
for your career well how are you going
to use your time outside of your job and
how are you going to regulate your
mental physical mental and physical
health and maybe also your drug and
alcohol use because that's that's a good
place to order down you know because
alcoholism for example wipes out you
know five to ten percent of people so
you want to keep that under control and
then and then so maybe you know you you
you develop a vision of what your life
what you would like your life to be and
that associates the so the goal once the
goal is established and then you break
down the goal
into micro processes that you can
implement the micro process has become
rewarding in proportion in relation to
their causal association with the goal
and that tangles in your your incentive
reward system you know we talked about
the dopaminergic incentive reward system
and that's the thing that keeps you
moving forward and the way it works is
that it works better if it produces
positive emotion when it can see you
moving towards a valued goal okay well
what's the implication of that better
have a valued goal because otherwise you
can't get any positive motivation
working out and so the more valuable the
goal in principle the more the micro
process is associated with that goal
start to take on a positive charge and
so what that means is well you get up in
the morning and you're excited about the
day you're ready to go
and so as far as I can tell what you do
is you specify your long term ideal
maybe you also specify a place you want
to stay the hell away from so that
you're terrified to fail as well as
excited about succeeding because that's
also useful you specify your goal you do
that you do that in some sense as a
unique individual you want to you want
to specify goals that make you say oh if
that could happen as a consequence of my
efforts it would clearly be worthwhile
because the question always is why do
something because doing nothing is easy
you just sit there and you don't do
anything that's real easy the question
is why would you ever do anything and
the answer that has to be because you've
determined by some means that it's
worthwhile and then the next question
might be well where should you look for
worthwhile things and one would be well
you could consult your own temperament
and now there would be well you kind of
look at how look at what it is that
people accrue that's valuable across the
lifespan look look what so you do a
structural analysis of the sub
components of human existence and
already did that you need a family you
need friends like you don't need to have
all these things but you better have
most of them
family friends career educational goals
plans for you know time outside of work
attention to your mental and physical
health etc you know those are that's
what life is about and if you don't have
any of those things well then all you've
got left is misery and suffering so
that's that's bad
that's a bad deal for you so so once you
but once you set up that that goal
structure let's say and that's really in
many in many ways that's what you should
be doing at universities is that's
exactly what you should be doing is
trying to figure out who it is that
you're trying to be right and you aim at
that and then use everything you learn
as a means of building that person that
you want to be and and I really mean
want to be I don't mean should be even
those things those things are going to
overlap and it's important to
distinguish between those because that's
partly and this is back down to the
micro routine analysis so I started
saying well you're going to try to make
yourself more industrious okay number
one specify your damn goals because how
are you going to hit something if you
don't know what it is that isn't going
to happen and often people won't specify
their goals too because they don't like
to specify conditions for failure so if
you keep yourself all vague and foggy
which is real easy because that's just a
matter of not doing as well then you
don't know when you fail and people
might say well I really don't want to
know when I fail because that's painful
so I'll keep myself blind about when I
fail that's fine except you'll fail all
the time then you just won't know it
until you failed so badly that you're
done and that can easily happen by the
time you're 40 so so I would recommend
that you don't let that happen
so that's willful blindness right you
could have known but you chose not to
okay so once you get your goal structure
set up you think okay if I could have
this life it looks like that might be
worth living despite the fact that it's
going to be you know anxiety provoking
and threatening and there's going to be
some suffering and loss involved in all
of that obviously the goal is to have a
vision for your life such that all
things considered that justifies your
effort okay so then what do you do well
then then you turn down to the micro
routine it's like okay well this is what
I'm aiming for how does that instantiate
itself day to day week to week month to
month and that's where something like a
schedule can be unbelievably useful
Google Calendar it's like make a damn
schedule and stick to it
okay so what's the rule with the
schedule it's not a bloody prison that's
the first thing that people do wrong is
well I don't like to follow a schedule
looks like well what kind of schedule
are you setting up
I have to do this then I have to do this
then I have to do this you know and then
I just go play video games because who
wants to do all these things that I have
to do it's like wrong set the damn
schedule up so that you have the day you
want that's the trick it's like okay
I've got tomorrow if I was going to set
it up so the best possible day I could
have practically speaking what would it
look like well then you schedule that
and obviously there's a bit of
responsibility that's going to go along
with that because if you have any sense
one of the things that you're going to
insist upon is that at the end of the
day you're not in worse shape than you
were that then at the beginning of the
day right
that's a stupid day if you have a bunch
of those in a row you just dig you know
you dig yourself a hole and then you
bury yourself in it's like sorry that's
just not a good strategy it's a bad
strategy
so maybe 20% of your day has to be
responsibility and obligation or maybe
it's more than that depending on how far
behind you are but even that you can you
can ask yourself okay well I've got
these responsibilities I have to
schedule the damn things in what's the
right ratio of responsibility to reward
and you can ask yourself that just like
you'd ago she ate with someone who is
working for you it's like okay you got
to work tomorrow
okay so I want you to work tomorrow and
you might say okay well what are you
going to do for me that makes it likely
that I'll work for you well you could
ask yourself that you know maybe you do
an hour of responsibility and then you
play a video game for 15 minutes I don't
know whatever turns your crank man but
you know you have to negotiate with
yourself and not tyrannize yourself like
you're negotiating with someone that you
care for that you would like to be
productive and have a good life and and
that's how you make the schedule it's
like and then you look today and you
think well if I had that day that'd be
good great you know I knew you're
useless and horrible so you'll probably
only hit it with about 70% accuracy but
that beats the hell out of zero right
and if you hit it even with 50% accuracy
another rule is well aim for 51% the
next week or 50 and a half percent for
God's sake or because you're going to
hit that position where things start to
loop back positively and spiral you
upward and so so that's one way that you
can work on your conscientious
a plan of life you'd like to have and
and you do that partly by referring to
social norms that's more or less
rescuing your father from the belly of
the whale but the way other way you do
that is by having a little conversation
with yourself about as if you don't
really know who you are because you know
what you like you won't do what you're
told you won't do what you tell yourself
to do you must have noticed that it's
like you're a bad employee and a worse
boss and both of those work you know for
you you don't know what you want to do
and then when you tell yourself what to
do you don't do it anyways you should
fire yourself and find someone else to
be but but you know my point is is that
you have to understand that you're not
your own servant so to speak you're
someone that you have to negotiate with
and that's and you're someone that you
want to present the opportunity of
having a good life to and that's hard
for people because they don't like
themselves very much so you know they're
always like cracking the whip and then
procrastinating and cracking the whip
and then procrastinating and it's like
god it's so boring and such a pathetic
way of spending your time and you know
what that's like because you probably
waste like six hours a day and I think
we did an economic calculation about
that a while back right your time is
probably worth 50 bucks an hour
something like that I mean you're not
getting paid that now but you're young
and so this is investment time and what
you do now is going to multiply its
effects in the future so so let's say
it's 50 bucks an hour which is perfectly
reasonable so if you weigh six hours a
day and you are then you're wasting
about $2,000 a week or about $100,000 a
year so like go ahead but that's what
it's costing you every hour and you need
to know what your damn time is worth so
let's say it's not 50 bucks it's 30
whatever maybe it's a hundred it's
somewhere in that range one of the
things you should be asking yourself is
when you spend an hour was that well
what have I paid someone 50 bucks to
have had that hour and if the answer is
no it's like well maybe you should do
something else with your time and it
depends on whether or not you think that
your time is worth while but the funny
thing about not assuming that is if you
assume your time isn't worthwhile what
happens is you don't just sit around
sort of randomly in a state of
responsibility let's bliss what you do
is you suffer existentially and so that
seems like a stupid solution